(audience applauding)
So your friends are having babies in quarantine,
but you found it love in quarantine.
As a single woman I'm just curious how?
It's so weird, believe me.
I still cannot get over the fact that it happened
because I remember in quarantine, I was like,
cool, so I'm single now and I can't meet anybody.
And I'm like, I guess I'll go on a dating app,
but I always said, I would never go on a dating app.
And then I found myself on a dating app and I was like,
I hate myself!
So I was like, I gotta get off of that.
And so I kind of just gave up for a minute
and I was working on Tick, Tick... Boom!
And my girlfriend was on this Zoom meditation group weekly.
And she's like, would you wanna hop on?
And I was like, of course, I love that.
They added me to a group text
and everyone's sending like GIFs of themselves.
So it's like Joe Jonas and like Wilmer Valderrama.
And so like I sent a GIF of myself
and then there's like a GIF in the group chat
of a baseball player and he's sliding onto a base
and I thought it was a joke.
So I just responded, hot.
(Drew laughing)
(Vanessa laughing)
And then I get on the Zoom and I'm like,
who is that?
And I found him and we started talking and,
yeah, it's wild that, you know,
we found each other over Zoom.
Wait, did you like slip into his DMs?
Did you say on the group text
like how did you navigate that?
Because I'm actually asking
as a woman because I think that I'm still weirdly
as much as I'm like empowered.
I think I still have that stigma
that like the man is supposed to do that initial step.
And I don't even know if that's the right way
to go about it anymore.
I mean, I'm such a go-getter.
I'm like, if I want something
or someone I'm going after 'em.
I fully just slid into his DMs and was like,
hey, it was nice to meet you.
So I think there is no shame in making the first move
if you want it, why wait for someone else
to give you what you want?
Well, I think I'm gonna take your advice
of don't be so old-fashioned.
Follow through, be a woman who is empowered both at work
and in life and with friendships as well as romance.
Exactly, go after what, let him know.
(Vanessa giggling)
Now, you were talking about Tick, Tick... Boom!
Which I'm so excited about.
And you were filming, it's Lin-Manuel is directing, right?
Lin-Manuel Miranda.
I think the Shakespeare of our times
and Andrew Garfield's in it.
Tell me about it.
Yeah, so I'm a big Jonathan Larson fan.
I was introduced to his work
when I did Rent at the Hollywood Bowl.
Did the summer production, played Mimi,
fell in love with the world
that Jonathan Larson wrote and created,
and so after that, I then did Rent: Live,
played a different character, got to meet like his family,
Jonathan's family.
They were always there, his sister and his dad,
and it just felt like I really was being integrated
into like the legacy that is Jonathan Larson.
And then I heard about Tick, Tick... Boom!
And I was like, I have to be a part of this movie
in whatever capacity.
And I ended up getting to play a part where I am one
of Jonathan Larson's backup vocalists.
Jonathan played by Andrew Garfield.
And it's just really, really special
because Tick, Tick... Boom!
He wrote for himself as a one-man play
and it's pretty autobiographical.
And it just really sets the tone
and gives you a peek into what it was like
being a struggling artist in the '90s,
in the Lower East Side of New York.
I can't wait for this.
I truly, Jonathan Larson, Lin-Manuel, you, Andrew Garfield.
And you got a tattoo to commemorate the end of it.
This tattoo, it says, "Cages or Wings"
because that's one of the lyrics in the movie.
And it's just so beautiful because he wrote this
in the '90s and the lyrics are so relevant.
And still to this day and the hook is, cages or wings?
Which do you prefer?
Ask the birds.
Fear or love, baby?
Don't say the answer, actions speak louder than words.
And I just think that it's so beautiful.
So I needed it on my body.
I love that.
I got a new tattoo yesterday on the show which was so fun.
And it says, home is where we are,
for me and my girls.
But one thing I always wanted to do as well was, you know,
go out there in the world.
As much as I was a creative, I loved business too.
And I love sharing things and I love being a curator.
And now you have Caliwater and I'm so excited about this.
Will you please tell us about this as I crack one open?
Yeah, of course.
Oh, the face, I love it!
I love watching people try it for the first time.
It's my favorite thing ever!
Oh, my gosh, this is amazing,
and it has prickly pear, tell me everything.
Yeah, this Caliwater, you're drinking the ginger and lime.
The original flavor is prickly pear.
And I was on a road trip through New Mexico
and there were prickly pear margaritas everywhere.
And being the margarita aficionado that I am,
I was like, oh, I gotta give this a try.
Fell in love.
And I was like, what is this prickly pear thing?
I've never really heard that much about it.
And I looked it up and realized that there have
been people for decades, hundreds of years,
centuries using prickly pears like a health remedy.
So I hit up my friend, Ollie, Oliver Trevena
and I knew that he was trying to do a beverage.
And so I was like, I think that we gotta do
this prickly pear thing and worked really hard
to put together the perfect concoction.
So it has so many amazing properties.
There's so many antioxidants, which is great for your skin.
There's more electrolytes in it than coconut water.
Whenever I'm hungover, I drank 'em,
whenever I am trying to like make a cocktail,
I use it as a mixer.
Like it kind of does it all and it's just delicious.
I mean, if that isn't like a ringing endorsement
of why to drink this.
I'm drinking the prickly pear now and it's so beautiful.
And I think
people,
you know, they want sort of guidance
and advice on things to enjoy in life.
And I love that you're leading the way
with this beautiful product
and I'm just so happy to see you and check in with you.
And I will be more bold out there in the world
in honor of your boldness
and make sure that you all go online today
and order some Caliwater.
We're gonna feature it on our website,
but it's gonna blow up and everybody's gonna be drinking it.
And it's gonna be amazing, thank you Vanessa so much.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
It's so wonderful to see you!
(upbeat music)